[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
starting with very disappointing news
for any good New England Patriots fan
like the staff of this program a
Patriots owner Robert Kraft 77 year old
billionaire has been wrapped up in a
prostitution sting he is on surveillance
video
receiving sexual services according to
police one of two dozen people who were
caught in this police thing as part of a
human trafficking probe in Florida and
you know what Pat I think at this point
you know before it was like all right
Bob Kraft is friends with Donald Trump
but he doesn't seem to be a particularly
conservative guy and he still does a lot
of great stuff and
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
is it now no longer plausibly defensible
that Robert Kraft is a good guy or are
we of the mindset that soliciting
prostitution is no big deal I take the
mindset that ignorance is bliss when it
comes to his ownership of the New
England Patriots but certainly we can
criticize him for this when the story
initially broke I thought that he was
actually involved in the human
trafficking because the guy's a
billionaire I just imagine that he had
connections and was actually in charge
of soliciting the prostitution that he
wasn't just you know someone who was
purchasing the services for himself so
when it came out that he just was
attending one of these salons for his
own pleasure I guess that the cost of
like only 59 to $79 that was so
surprising to me
very surprising well I'm sure he was
leaving really big tips and everybody
was really happy with it so far we have
not heard I've not seen any kind of
formal comment from Kraft about this
although maybe there is one buried
somewhere interestingly this is a
misdemeanor in Florida I don't know if
let's see if I can find that
solicitation of prostitution felony
let's
see where it is a felony if anywhere
[Music]
okay maybe it's not the easiest piece of
information to find in any case in
Florida it's a misdemeanor so more than
likely this is going to not really go to
too far particularly this is given that
he is 77 years old will have access to
extremely good lawyers so I don't expect
too much of a penalty here for Robert
Kraft but this has got to be seriously
damaging to his reputation as an NFL
owner right I mean among LF a NFL owners
is the guy who was caught soliciting $79
sexual favors going to be treated
seriously at owners meetings maybe so
because the Patriots have been so
successful I think you're right that
this is going to hit him hard within
that circle but among New Englanders do
England Patriots fans I don't think that
many people are going to care
I really don't and a side point here in
nationally enough another billionaire
was caught up in this - what are they
doing down there like I would have to
imagine that there are other ways which
are billionaire I didn't hear about that
not not a well-known billionaire someone
whose net worth is only slightly above a
billion dollars so maybe he's not even
worth discussing really he's not like
Robert Kraft or one of these bigger
names but it's just weird how this all
works like what are these incredibly
powerful rich people doing at this
random Florida salon I don't get it
yeah I mean I'm not okay so
I've never solicited prostitution and
I'm not an expert in how I would do it
but I visited Las Vegas enough times to
know that if you have money as Robert
Kraft does you don't need to do this if
you're looking to pay for companionship
so to speak there are high-end discreet
escort services which if you spend
enough time in Vegas you start to
identify generally speaking men who are
clearly on dates with with escorts see
it seems like that is far lower risk
like maybe I don't understand why like
maybe there's something special for a
billionaire like Robert Kraft
that makes it more appealing or exciting
in some way to go to a place like this
in Florida and pay 79 bucks
rather than having like one of these
discreet professional type services like
what Eliot Spitzer was wrapped up in or
others but I just don't get why you
would even end up doing this if you have
the amount of money that Robert Kraft
has exactly that's why I'm so perplexed
why wouldn't he just pay the extra money
and do it in a more discreet way and I
think you know many people don't see a
problem with this service and maybe
there wouldn't be a problem with it if
it was totally legalized and regulated
but unfortunately many of the women
there were essentially slaves they
weren't allowed to leave the property
and you can't be wrapped up in that you
can't be supporting an industry like
that nope and to be clear the police
have said that although there were many
people like you pad who thought that he
was potentially involved in the
trafficking element of it that he is not
it's not even suspected that he's
involved in that he was just the John as
they are known I think that there's
something offensive about using that
term I don't remember what it is
it means offensive to people named John
who don't solicit prostitution maybe so
maybe so so we'll see what happens with
Robert Kraft very very sad day and
listen I like Tom Brady I like the
Patriots I that's it I don't have
anything else to say positive about
Robert Kraft
at this point in time and I probably
won't for a very long time a military
draft that applies only to men is
unconstitutional according to a federal
judge in Houston who says that excluding
women is no longer justified because now
they can serve in combat roles just as
men do this relates to what is called
Selective Service now nobody has
actually been conscripted into the US
military in more than 40 years since the
Vietnam War but there's this thing
called the military Selective Service
Act which requires that all American men
register when they turn 18 if a draft is
reinstated they would be eligible
through age 25 if you don't register you
can be fined you can be imprisoned you
can be denied services like federal
student loans now this ruling says women
are fully integrated into the military
and it would not be constitutional to
tempt women from the Selective Service
registration I agree completely Pat I
mean it's not controversial I'm against
the National Selective Service Act I
don't think we should have a draft I
signed up when I turned 18 but I don't
think there's any good reason that women
should not have to participate yeah I
agree
against the draft against Selective
Service but if men have to sign up I
think that women have to as well and
that just you know goes to the 14th
amendment to the Constitution equal
protection under the law but I think you
know this is probably an issue that's
being blown out of proportion by like
the men's rights activists who brought
it forward we talked about some you know
issues like free speech on college
campuses and you know maybe there is a
discussion to be had there may be there
are issues but in terms of issues facing
the country maybe that ranks like 63rd
women not currently signing up for
Selective Service
I think and in the scope and scale of
issues that we have in this country that
maybe ranks like one thousandth oh you
think it's even lower that's it I think
it's like I mean I actually think that
listen I'm not a men's rights activist I
am it's a movement that I find to be
disgusting in a lot of ways I think that
you don't you know broken clocks are
right twice a day I happen to agree that
if we have citizenship and we aren't a
sort of two-tiered system if when you
turn 18 you have to register in the
event that there is a draft both men and
women serve in the military women can
serve in combat roles it would be an
inequality that is not a fair inequality
to only require men to register so I
think that you know listen is it a
thousandth on our list of priorities or
500 or 78th I don't know but you can't
really have a situation where men and on
the basis of gender one's rights and
responsibilities as a citizen differ and
it shouldn't differ with regards to
ability to vote
it shouldn't differ with regard to
ability to own land or whatever and it
shouldn't differ with regards to
Selective Service so I think it's the
right decision yeah I agree a big a
victory you could say for the men
rights activists I guess they'll be on
to their next pursuit pretty soon now
yeah I guess so
okay let's talk about I don't want to
call this ad pocalypse 2.0 because it's
only had a very measured a very small
impact modest impact on the David Pakman
show YouTube channel maybe like a five
to eight percent hit to our ad revenue
on YouTube but a bunch of big brands are
starting to pull ads off of YouTube over
concerns that potential sexual predators
are gathering in comment sections of
videos to prey on children that are
being featured and YouTube has now
deleted more than 400 channels and
suspended comments on tens of millions
of videos as they're trying to purge
their platform of what they consider to
be pedophiles this is I don't even it's
it's very creepy and I don't even really
know how to fully explain it but there
are videos that feature children and
they're not directly featuring children
in ways that are wrong or illegal in any
way but there are groups that are sort
of focusing on taking screenshots or
pausing these videos when the children
in the videos are in what could be in a
freeze frame sort of misconstrued as a
suggestive pose it means really
disgusting what's going on and they are
posting comments that are in a sort of
code that they've developed and it's
just as vile as you can imagine and
understandably YouTube doesn't want
anything to do with this advertisers
don't want anything to do with this
but it does have the risk of starting to
once again impact channels like ours
that are doing nothing wrong so we're
keeping a close eye on it Pat I hope it
doesn't develop into ad pocalypse 2.0
but Disney has pulled ads Nestle has
pulled ads Epic Games has pulled ads
AT&T and Hasbro are out so once these
brands start pulling ads it can affect a
wide range of channels and I've seen
some trolls deliberately posting really
creepy stuff as comments on our videos
even though they're nonsense
Twitter's to try to get YouTube system
to flag us so far I don't think that's
been working but this could get bad
pretty quickly yeah there could be a
slippery slope here
AT&T put out a quote saying until Google
can protect our brand from offensive
content of any kind we are removing all
advertising from YouTube I mean what
kind of standard is that any offensive
content is what we do here on the show
offensive I would certainly say no but
some could consider it offensive because
we have viewpoints that aren't always
going along with the majority
right-wingers could say maybe we're
saying offensive things here so you'd
never be able to guarantee that and I
wonder if AT&T will ever come back as an
advertiser on YouTube also there's the
question of if that really does hurt
their brand like back in the original ad
pocalypse days April 2017 there was a
controversy about a coca-cola ad being
placed next to a neo-nazi promoting
video and like I don't think that the
average viewer coming across that clip
for one reason or another is going to
associate coca-cola with neo-nazis I
think people are so used to seeing
advertisements everywhere on the
Internet
that they understand it's not like the
two are directly related to each other I
tend to agree I tend to agree with you I
mean if you talk about you know some of
these videos some of these videos are
probably being produced in a way that is
meant to quietly appeal to pedophiles I
don't deny that but a lot of these
videos are like family vacation videos
where screen shots are being taken at a
moment where some girl is moving through
the frame and if you pause it in exactly
the right place it's sort of creepy and
sexually suggestive if an AT&T ad played
before that isn't that really damaging a
teen C's brand I just don't think so I
really don't see it and I mean I don't
want to call it a cop-out because if
advertising on YouTube is profitable for
AT&T I don't know why they would need a
cop-out to stop or to start they would
just say it's either profitable or not
profitable to advertise on YouTube so I
find it a little weird that that's still
being claimed as the reason by some of
these brands but there is this aversion
to risk that
significant once you get huge
corporations and apparatus and apparatus
that includes a ton of lawyers involved
I guess they're being as risk-averse as
possible and hopefully it will not come
back to hurt channels like ours that are
just trying to provide independent news
and commentary and political analysis so
we will follow it if it gets bad I will
absolutely let you know but so far muted
February often not the busiest month on
YouTube and we're you know maybe down
like 5% or something like that it may
not even have to do with what's going on
it's always hard to track down reasoning
exactly but we'll see how far it goes
and we'll see how far YouTube has to go
in their effort to kind of put a lid on
this problem send me your thoughts
that's it for today new show new bonus
show tomorrow the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]